[Music]
foreign
my name is Jordan Shea I'm a
groundskeeper professional football
today I'm going to guide you through the
process of deep cleaning and preparing
an NFL field for the Super Bowl
[Music]
I started groundskeeping for the Los
Angeles Memorial Coliseum and USC in
2016. from there I went on to Sofi
stadium in 2021 when I found out the
Super Bowl was coming to Sofi Stadium it
was very exciting to know that I would
have the opportunity to be a part of
such a big event when you're working in
a higher scale setting such as
professional football there are a lot
more fine details that go into all the
planning and the execution when it comes
to events and preparation as well as
cleanup
the first step to Preparing the field
for the Super Bowl is removing the paint
from the previous game
so the machine that we use to clean the
field is called a p-rex and what it does
is their brushes with very strong
bristles and a circular shape that go
down and scrub the paint off after we
spray down a solution
[Music]
we have somebody driving each and every
one and there are a few out there on the
field after the game ends
once the paint is starting to break up
and be liquid there's a vacuum that
sucks the excess paint into a tank
these machines have something that
sprays the tires in order to remove the
paint from them so there's no tracking
and that way we don't get paint in spots
that we don't want it when it's time to
get new brushes and drain the tank then
we drive into our wash station we start
the cleaning process of the p-rex
so right now we're removing the used
brushes spraying them off to get all the
paint off storing them off to the side
so they can dry and putting a new brush
onto each p-rex in order to send it back
out and start cleaning again it's time
to fill up the tanks with water and the
paint removing solution we dumped the
tank that filters the rubber out of the
used paint and then from there we
dispose of the paint
so the brushes on the p-rex go down onto
the turf and spin as well as the
operator drives the machine back and
forth in order to remove paint from a
certain area mixed with the solution I'd
say the removal process can take
anywhere from two to four hours we just
keep going until we don't see any more
paint on the field and it's good to go
and ready for the next paint day
now that we've finished removing all the
paint from the field and it's clear to
go for the next paint day we can start
the process of painting
foreign
the process of painting for the Super
Bowl is different from any other game
because there is a whole other crew that
is also involved in the painting
so the preparation process for the Super
Bowl starts at least two weeks ahead of
the actual game
When painting for the Super Bowl there
are different logos that we've never
used before new stencils so we have to
map out where everything goes and
measure the spots for these specific
stencils and that may be in a spot on
the field that has never been painted
before
foreign
so while we paint these logos we want
the lines and edges to be straight we
have straight edges and we have flimsy
boards that can be set on specific spots
in order to prevent the paint from
getting into a spot that it's not
supposed to be in
[Music]
so after we get done painting it's time
to clean the equipment these boards we
take to the back washroom and we use
solution to get the paint off
so this paint board is caked in paint
with multiple layers so you need to
spray scrape and use solution until we
get it all off
[Music]
paint dust splatter paint does get
everywhere so we need to make sure the
entire machine is clean takes a little
while in order to get all the paint off
but once it's clean it looks great and
it's worth it
[Music]
so it's important to clean the paint
machines because
one you want to take care of the
equipment that you use make sure that it
can last as long as you would like it to
last you don't want paint buildup in
certain areas on the machine because
then that can start to limit the
functionality of the machine
washing the confetti rain down on the
field is surreal and I would not trade
that feeling for the world until I
realize that we were going to have to
clean it up so to clean this confetti up
we're using as many blowers as we have
in order to bring all the confetti to
one side of the field in one area so we
can shovel it up and pour it in the
trash can remove and just keep doing it
over and over and over until it's all
gone
once the confetti is cleaned up we use a
machine called a litter cat to remove
excess debris from the field
the litter cat is part of our daily
maintenance but it is important to use
it after the games as well because there
are a lot of pieces of debris that get
onto the field the first part of the
machine is going to suck up the lighter
debris and the back end of the machine
is a magnet that will remove all the
metal from the fields
when we're removing the debris out of
the litter cap we tend to find a lot of
screws from players helmets small pieces
of metal small pieces of plastic as well
as sunflower seed shells
my favorite thing about being a
groundskeeper is a team aspect I work
with a lot of great people it's fun to
be around them and to work towards a
common goal of making sure playing
surface is working great for something
of such magnitude being a part of the
Super Bowl process is something that I
wouldn't trade for the world it was a
surreal feeling and I'm excited to watch
this year's Super Bowl
[Music]